great hi guys welcome to Friday I read
this week so much happened and so little
of my voice is left if you didn't know
Friday it's a look back and my week and
blog for him
so because so many things happened let's
just start looking back at it oh but
before we start looking back at it don't
forget to watch the most recent episode
of hay USA at the scene calm here's the
thing for it yeah
season 2 it looks good on you it's a
really great season really fun things
happen check out the newest episode I
haven't seen meerkat we're talking about
the newest social media platforms here
cam and periscope and we're we're here
getting ready for Shane and there's Wes
see us remember Shane and Hilary and I
tried to prank members of production
team and crew three times and came up
empty three times this is the calm
before the pillory Shane Dawson storm
everyone else is in here getting pumped
just normal pumped atmosphere at level
Oh guys so you should know this by now
but I'm leaving for DC two nights I'm
going to the White House Correspondents
Dinner as a guest of the Huffington Post
with Arianna Huffington and because of
that Elizabeth brought all these
beautiful dresses for me to try on and I
picked one that I'm wearing I had worn a
long dress since prom yeah yeah they
ready to film Davos here super excited I
brought his favorite accessory a
steadycam Evo's personality is just like
his camera steady and oh it's following
me
we're here in Black Angus above like we
showed off its me not Hilary Duff it's a
mile
I chain Dawson you look really cool with
the moon behind you and everything denim
I was scared you're gonna wear denim
over he look like Britney and Jess oh my
god I wish this looks like a bit like a
Twilight book cover right now how was
meeting the duck mom scary yes I shook
her hand I was shaking the whole time
she was she was really nice um and I was
very intimidated by her like she's the
dog right well also I heard that we're
not supposed to call in the Deaf because
of that movie well nobody wants to be
the designated ugly fat friend mister
off oh I don't know should I've been
asking her those kind of questions like
if the Helbig came out it's like the big
dumb [ __ ]
we made a DC I supposed to go the
Correspondents Dinner and nine hours go
the hotel first hello guys we are
officially in Washington DC I just run
and now I'm going to shower and try and
put myself together for the
Correspondents Dinner tonight I'm so out
of the loop I know nothing about nothing
right now I know nothing about
everything right now I should say so I
started looking up like who are the
guests
what is the correspondents this is very
intimidating
they actually explain what's going on so
what's happening is Arianna Huffington
from The Huffington Post has a table at
the White House Correspondents Dinner
and essentially the White House
Correspondents Dinner from what I gather
is this like glamorous Hollywood ask
night in DC where the president gets a
chance to kind of like roast all of his
people basically just like a fun funny
schmooze night I assume but all these
different news outlets have tables at
the dinner and Huffington Post has a
table and they have decided with their
table to invite social media influencers
thankfully people like Bethany Mota and
Tyler Oakley will be at this table
because I know no one cars come for us
in like an hour and a half so I'm gonna
shower and try and clean myself up the
other thing is I don't have like makeup
artists or hair person or whatever and
it's a black-tie event so I'm gonna
attempt to do stuff to my face and hair
that other people have been doing for me
for a few weeks now but let me show you
the dress this is the dress whoa very
sexy which is essentially my entire
style encompassed in a way - the sexy as
I wear a men's H&M shirt let's get ready
for the event
there's something looming in the
distance that we're gonna go save
concrete jungle
this is so insane hold on got it
who deliver well it's happening it's all
happening so our line is a new Fantastic
point of view
I'm gonna kill you
good morning it is Monday it's Monday
morning and we're on a bus tour but look
at all of the posters and billboards
around New York City like I'm excited so
excited I guess they have to call back
man you gotta call me yeah you know it's
a different world now
hi guys we're backstage at brandcast
look at this
Wow Wow they're glamorous all very very
glamorous
I like hashtag there's no wow what a
week
that was crazy now I'm back in Los
Angeles and I'm getting ready for the
great show newest episode tonight with
Shane Dawson Hilary Duff and glozell
it's gonna be really good
also we have officially announced that
for memories book which is coming out
the end of May we are doing another
round of nofilter shows the links to my
tickets are down below go check it out
because it's an exciting thing once we
figure out what the show will be and
also preorder memories book why not book
calm I don't know who the little Oh it's
happening it's all happening